Nadia está en la casa mientras Pedro está
en la escuela.
La distancia que separa la casa de la escuela
es de 6km.
Ellos empiezan a viajar hacia la dirección
del otro al mismo tiempo.
Si Nadia va caminando
a una velocidad de 3.5 km/h,
y Pedro va caminando
a una velocidad de 6 km/h,
¿cuándo se encontrarán  y a qué distancia estarán
de la casa cuando se encuentren?
Y bueno, vamos a suponer
que aquí tenemos
a Nadia, aquí tenemos a Pedro, la distancia
entre la casa y la escuela son 6 km
y van en dirección el uno al otro, por lo tanto
Nadia va a una velocidad de 3.5 km/h...
déjame ponerlo más grande...
km/h...
mientras que Pedro
va a una velocidad de 6 km/h...
6 km/h...
y bueno, va hacia acá...
Ahora, date cuenta que ello se van a intersectar
en algún punto, por lo tanto vamos a poner
al punto en donde se van a intersectar
justo por aquí,
voy a decir que aquí se van a intersecta
r y bueno,
date cuenta que como
Pedro va más rápido, va a recorrer más distancia
de lo que va a recorrer Nadia, por
lo tanto, se van a intersectar en este punto,
y ahora sí, vamos a definir a "x" como la
distancia que hay de la casa
al punto en donde se intersectan,
que de hecho es una de las
que me preguntan,
la distancia de la casa
al punto donde se intersectan,
ésta va a ser "x".
Y bueno, ¿cómo puedo saber la otra distancia?
la distancia que recorre Pedro.
Para no hacernos más bolas y meter una nueva
variable, voy a decir que esto es 6 menos "x".
Perfecto, aquí ya tengo que la distancia
que recorre Nadia es "x",
mientras que la distancia
que recorre Pedro es 6 menos "x",
es decir, 6 km menos
la distancia que recorre  Nadia.
Ahora bien, para resolver este problema, lo
que voy a usar es una fórmula que ya hemos
visto varias veces y está muy metida
en nuestros videos de física.
Esta fórmula dice que la distancia es igual
a la velocidad por el tiempo
o la distancia es igual
a la rapidez por el tiempo.
Si utilizo esta fórmula para Nadia, me va
a quedar que "x" es igual a 3.5 por "t", la
distancia que recorre Nadia es "x",
la velocidad a la que va Nadia es 3.5 km/h y el tiempo es "t".
Bien, ahora hagamos lo mismo para Pedro.
Pedro va a recorrer una distancia de
6 menos "x" km y por la fórmula esto va a ser igual
a la velocidad que son 6 km/h, por el tiempo,
pero aquí hay algo muy importante que quiero
que te des cuenta,
tanto Nadia como Pedro
se van a encontrar al mismo tiempo,
porque justo esto
es lo que me dice el problema,
que salen en el mismo momento y por lo tanto,
va a pasar el mismo tiempo para que se encuentren.
Y ahora, ya tengo dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas
y ya puedo resolver este problema,
¿qué te parece si de esta ecuación sustituyo
el valor de "x" en nuestra segunda ecuación?
"x" es igual a "3.5t" y en lugar de "x" en
esta ecuación, voy a escribir "3.5t".
¿Y qué me va a quedar?
Que 6 menos "x", pero "x" vale "3.5t",
entonces 6 menos "3.5t"
esto tiene que ser igual a "6t"
y ahora si,
vamos a resolver para el tiempo,
ya no está tan difícil,
si yo paso esto del otro lado,
me va a quedar que 6 es igual aç
"6t" más "3.5t", "6t" más "3.5t"
es lo mismo que "9.5t".
Y ahora voy a dividir todo entre 9.5
para despejar al tiempo
y me queda que el tiempo
es igual a 6 entre 9.5,
pero bueno, 9.5 lo puedo ver
como un quebrado,
esto es lo mismo que 19/2,
entonces me quedaría,
6 entre 19/2,
9.5 es lo mismo que 19/2
y ahora si, si yo divido un número
entre un quebrado,
es lo mismo que multiplicar ese mismo número
por el recíproco de este quebrado,
y me va a quedar, 6 por 2 entre 19,
lo cual me da 12 entre 19,
12 entre 19 horas, es decir que
el tiempo en el que se van a encontrar los dos,
es 12 entre 19 horas.
Ahora bien,
tanto Nadia como Pedro se van
a intersectar en un punto
y bueno, ya es bien fácil sacar a "x",
porque "x" va a ser igual a 3.5 por el tiempo,
pero ya sé cuánto vale
el tiempo,
por cierto, 3.5
es lo mismo que 7/2,
7/2 lo voy a multiplicar por el tiempo,
pero el tiempo en el cual se encuentran los dos,
es 12 entre 19, por lo tanto
me va a quedar que "x" es igual
y voy a simplificar aquí un poco,
a 7 por 6 lo cual es 42,
42 entre 19...
42 entre 19 km
y esto estaba dando en horas
y por lo tanto, ya tengo la respuesta a este problema,
ellos se van a encontrar en un tiempo
de 2 entre 19 horas,
mientras que se van a intersectar a una distancia
de 42 entre 19 km de la casa.
Así que vamos a seguir hablando de Pedro,
y vamos a ver otro problema
que tenga que ver con Pedro.
Pedro compró algunas
de sus libretas para clases
en el supermercado a un precio de 2.25
pesos cada una y otras de sus libretas las
compró en una papelería a un precio
de 2  pesos cada una.
Si en total se gastó, en ambos lugares, la
misma cantidad de dinero y compró
17 libretas en total.
¿Cuántas libretas compró Pedro en cada lugar?
Así que vamos a empezar a definir variables.
Voy a decir que "s"
es la cantidad de libretas
que compró en el supermercado
y voy a decir que "r" es igual a la cantidad de libretas
que compró en la papelería...
Bueno, lo primero que voy a hacer es escribir
ecuaciones son "s" y "r" y
la primera que sé
es que "s" más "r"
tiene que ser igual a 17,
Pedro compró 17 libretas en total para
todo el año escolar, por lo tanto,
"s" más  "r" debe ser 17...
"s" más "r" debe de ser igual a 17.
Esto es el primer dato que me dan, y bueno,
ya está escrito en una ecuación.
Ahora, también me dan el dato de que Pedro
gastó la misma cantidad de dinero en ambos lugares,
es decir, la cantidad de dinero que
gastó en el supermercado al comprar las libretas,
es exactamente igual que la cantidad de dinero
que gastó en la papelería al comprar las libretas,
eso lo puedo poner de la siguiente
manera,
como hablo de que tienen la misma cantidad
de dinero, pues entonces me quedaría que
la cantidad de libretas que compró en el
supermercado, por el precio que costaba cada
una de las libretas, es decir, 2.25 por la
cantidad de libretas que compró en el supermercado,
es decir "s", esto es lo que se gastó
en el supermercado,
esto me dicen que es exactamente igual
a la cantidad de dinero que se gastó
en las libretas que compró en la papelería,
es decir, voy a multiplicar la cantidad de
libretas que compró en la papelería por
el precio que gastó en la papelería, que
son 2 pesos, por lo tanto me quedaría,
2 por "r", esto es lo que se gastó en al papelería
al comprar sus libretas.
Muy bien, entonces tengo que
"2.25s" es igual a "2r"
y ya está bien fácil resolver este problema,
porque entonces
puedo sustituir,
ya sea "s" o a "r", en mi primera ecuación.
Y para esto voy a despejar a una de estas
dos variables, creo que es más fácil despejar a "r",
por lo tanto, de esta ecuación de
aquí abajo, voy a despejar a "r" para sustituirla
en el valor de arriba.
Entonces para despejar a "r", lo que tengo
que hacer es dividir 2.25 entre 2,
me va a quedar
que 2.25 entre 2 por "s",
esto tiene que ser igual a "r",
muy bien.
Y ya con este valor de "r",
lo que voy a hacer
es sustituir el valor de "r"
en mi primera ecuación,
es decir,
voy a meter este valor aquí,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Que "s" más "r", pero en lugar de "r" recuerda
que voy a poner 2.25 entre 2 por "s",
entonces me va a quedar
"s" más 2.25 entre 2 por "s",
esto tiene que ser igual a 17,
ya sustituí el valor de "r" que me dice mi segunda ecuación,
ahora, 1 por "s" es lo mismo
que 2/2 por "s",
entonces en lugar
de "s" voy a escribir 2/2 de "s"
para que sea mucho más fácil hacer esta
operación,
2/2 de "s" más 2.25 entre 2 po "s", r
¿cuánto es esto?
Pues esto es lo mismo que 4.25 entre 2 por "s"
y esto tiene que ser igual a 17,
y ahora si, despejando de aquí a "s",
¿qué me va a quedar?
Para esto lo que voy a hacer, es pasar a este quebrado
a esta fracción del otro lado,
multiplicándola por su recíproco, es decir 2 entre 4.25,
de tal manera que del lado izquierdo todo
esto se va y me queda solamente que "s"
es igual a 17 por 2, lo cual es 34 entre 4.25.
Y habrá que hacer esta operación.
Bueno, para no hacer toda la división, lo
que voy a hacer es ver a 4.25
como 4 enteros 1/4,
4.25 es 4 enteros 1/4, que esto es exactamente
lo mismo que 4 por 4 = 16 más 1 = 17/4.
Y bueno, de igual manera lo que voy a hacer
es multiplicar por el recíproco
y me va a quedar 34 por 4 entre 17,
pero ¿qué crees?
34 y 17 se pueden simplificar...
aquí se va...
y me queda solamente 2 por 4,
lo cual es 8,
es decir,
que la cantidad de libretas que
compró este Pedro
en el supermercado es 8
y por lo tanto,
ya podemos saber cuantas libretas
compró en la papelería.
Si de esta misma ecuación, de una manera rápida,
de aquí despejo a "r",
me va a quedar que "r" es igual a 9.
Entonces,
ya también resolví este problema,
así que en lo que resta de video,
vamos a resolver otro problema más que tenga que
ver también con Pedro
y en esta ocasión también con Nadia.
Y dice, Pedro está viendo a los cerdos y a las gallinas
en la granja, Pedro tiene una granja.
Y Nadia, por su parte, está adentro de la
casa y no puede ver a los animales.
¡Entonces a Pedro se le ocurre un acertijo!,
le dice a Nadia que en total hay
13 cabezas de animales
y 36 patas de animales y le pregunta,
¿cuántos cerdos hay en la granja
y cuántas gallinas hay en la granja?
Entonces vamos a definir variables,
sea "p" la cantidad de cerdos
y sea "c" la cantidad
de gallinas.
Lo primero que sabemos es que "p" más "c"
tiene que ser igual a 13,
¿por qué?
porque cada cerdo tiene una cabeza
y cada gallina
tiene una cabeza
y si tenemos 13 cabezas en total,
por lo tanto, "p" más "c" tiene que
ser igual a 13.
Bueno, esto es por una parte, ahora date cuenta
que cada cerdo tiene 4 patas,
mientras que cada gallina tiene solamente 2 patas,
por lo tanto,
la cantidad de patas que tiene un cerdo,
por la cantidad de cerdos,
más la cantidad de patas que tiene una gallina,
por la cantidad de gallinas, esto tiene que ser
igual a la cantidad de patas que hay en total,
es decir, 36.
Y es aquí donde radica la idea del acertijo de este Pedro,
porque se dio cuenta que cada
uno de los cerdos tiene solamente 4 patas
y cada una de las gallinas
solamente tiene 2 patas.
Y bueno, para resolver este sistema de ecuaciones,
lo voy a resolver por suma y resta,
entonces voy a multiplicar
por 2 la primera ecuación completita
y me va a quedar
"2p" más "2c" esto es igual a 26,
y ahora, si yo agarro la primera ecuación
y a esta ecuación le resto la segunda ecuación,
la segunda ecuación
que acabo de obtener,
ya voy a obtener de una manera muy sencilla
el valor de "p",
es decir,
cuantos cerdos tengo.
Y para esto entonces lo que voy a hacer, es
restar de la primera ecuación dos veces
la segunda ecuación y entonces todos esos se
convierten en menos,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
"4p" menos "2p" es "2p", "2c" menos "2c"
pues estos dos se van, se cancelan
y solamente me quedaría,
36 menos 26,
lo cual es 10
y ya está muy fácil esto, "p" vale 5.
Si paso dividiendo el 2 me va a quedar
que la cantidad de cerdos es igual a 5.
Y una vez que ya tengo la cantidad de cerdos,
sacar la cantidad de gallinas, ya es muy sencillo
porque obtengo que 5 más "x" es igual a 13
y si da aquí paso el 5 del otro lado con
signo contrario,
me queda que la cantidad de gallinas
es igual a 8.
Y esto gracias al método de suma y resta
y fíjate que tiene toda la lógica del mundo,
porque si yo sumo 8 más 5 me va a dar 13
y por otra parte, 4 patas porcinas por la
cantidad de cerdos que tenemos,
es 4 por 5
lo cual me daría 20
y después dos patas avícolas
por la cantidad de gallinas que tengo
me quedaría,
8 por 2 = 16,
20 más 16 es 36.
Tenemos 36 patas de animales en total,
por lo tanto, en la granja del buen Pedro,
había 5 cerdos y 8 gallinas.